getting sued, YouTubers. Can we just Can we just stop or can
we just put emphasis on the butt and then just disregard literally
everything before it? And then when Dan was making his argument,
Dan said, "But I don't care because anti-semitism.
I am I have to think about my children's future." And Nick was
like, "Yeah, no. This is my career." Yeah, true. Why? That's
why Twitch is a unique problem. That's his goal here is to try
to say Twitch is a unique problem. And it's not like you like
you said. Obviously Chud basically reacts to the exact same content
across both YouTube and Twitch. Yes, it's like I I can I'm sure
at some point he goes um yeah, I don't know, man. This this could
be dangerous, I guess. But I'm sure the rest of it is, oh my
god, I'm so glad Casey drops be financially ruined. Oh my god,
dude. Then they don't even give a they've got malicious intent.
Like how can this not be infringement? It's going to be that
like endlessly.
I had this Nick Deoro tweet up here that we're going to cover.
Um cuz I thought it was I thought it was pretty interesting.
Okay. I just thought it was a very interesting position that
we sort of described on stream a couple times
and I get it and I No, he didn't reply to Auggie. He just threw
like an opinion which I was just like that's an interesting opinion.
Okay, it's an interesting opinion.
Uh lawsuits and court rulings could potentially have scary consequences
for us moving forward, but I find it really hard to empathize
specifically with any of the streamers getting sued. YouTubers
complain. Can we just stop or can we just put emphasis on the
butt and then just disregard literally everything before it cuz
that's now now we can see what he's actually saying. Uh, sure,
sure, sure. Um, I just find it very funny how this maps onto
Willie Mack's thoughts about um death threats. This is very it's
like this uh but I find it really hard to empathize specifically
with any of the streamers getting sued. YouTubers complained
and practically begged these Twitch streamers for years to just
do the bare minimum. In return, they gave increasingly smug responses.
Uh, I believe it was like mostly XQC was giving the most smug
responses. Okay. I believe XQC was the most offensive. Again,
um, okay, it's fine. The culture on Twitch allowed for these
guys to use YouTube content as their lunch break or lunch or
bathroom breaks without any permission or meaningful interaction
with the material. It's comparable to Tik Tockers getting ripped
off by people exporting all their content on Insta reels. On
Twitch, people watch full TV shows and movies while collecting
ad revenue and donations. It was an absolute clown world. Uh,
I think this culture had broadly ended, right? Was anybody doing
this as a big streamer other than maybe Caseyron? Isn't he also
just giving you the exact reason why he has a hard time empathizing?
Cuz he's now portraying the us versus them mindset that he has.
Twitch vers YouTube and I'm on YouTube. So, actually, I can't
empathize with these people being targeted.
Well, I think it's uh the other thing is it's like the narrative
by which you can like still support all these lawsuits, right?
Oh, it's like Twitch streamer. It's Twitch culture. Yeah. Yeah.
I pointed that out because they're not going versus advertisers,
right? When Dan was going to the advertisers on Twitch, uh Dioro's
like reaction was like, "Hold on, hold on, cuz this happened
on YouTube and I'm not with that." That was like, "Put everybody
at risk." Blah blah blah blah. So now,
yeah, I don't know. I I think um yeah, I think this is broadly
like attacking a the the weird thing about to me about this is
it's attacking a Twitch culture that is like old like a Twitch
culture that basically I think the what do you call it the 2023
react stuff actually changed a decent amount. A lot of people
stopped doing precisely what was getting called out and started
becoming better about it. Asmin goes better about it. Realistically,
one of the only people who got like about it and didn't change
at all was XQC. I think like the
everything they saying just seems totally worthless cuz he like
Ethan could literally like show up and and just one of these
women and Nick would support it.
I know that but I'm having a hard time
having a hard time empathizing when they're like outright deniers
and they just get on stream all the time and deny the of Israeli
women. I just really can't empathize if like a Jewish guy just
goes and rescue to be honest. I I think ultimately, you know,
you know, maybe you shouldn't deny of that's that's the mindset
he's on right now. This just isn't even honest because this has
nothing to do with Twitch. This the things that Ethan is complaining
about could have been a YouTube streamer. He's just talking about
streamers versus people who upload curated content, right? His
buddy Logic is a streamer on
This last point's going to kind of differentiate, but it doesn't
really No, you're correct. But he's like trying to mislead here
because he's gonna point out Content ID. And Content ID exists,
but Content ID, as far as I know, is not anywhere near as accessible
to small channels. Like, am I crazy or do you have to pre-register
your stuff with Content ID in some way that most people can't?
Like, you don't just get the Content ID things live on streams
unless you have some sort of like additional access, right? Like
I know you can I know you can go to the copyright tab and pick
out your videos and being they're being used somewhere else and
you can DMCA automatically, but I don't think you get like the
live copyright um content ID stuff unless you register a video
in a specific way. But I am I went out of his way. I have no
idea. But he like Ethan went out of his way to register with
the Library of Congress before he had his nuke go live. So, if
he was going to be preemptive about that, I imagine he would
be able to and he has like the size enough to get his video content
IDed, which would would have prevented streamers that were on
YouTube from reacting to it. Many that did or like not hit or
anything like that, not flagged. I just don't there this just
mean anything.
Yeah. Well, he's trying to say that like Twitch is a bad platform
because they didn't implement Content ID, but it exists for songs
for one thing, and then it also I would say like I think they
try to do some kind of Content ID version with like reports.
Like they will they will dock you offline if you are streaming
movies and you get reported, right? But I think they do it more
manually. They probably spend money doing it. But uh he's trying
to point out that like YouTube is just better. And that's why
that's why Twitch is a unique problem. That's his goal here is
to try to say Twitch is a unique problem. And it's not like you
like you said, obviously Chud basically reacts to the exact same
content across both YouTube and Twitch. Yes. It essentially doesn't
affect his uh his job. And then the argument that oh well what
happens to Twitch streamers won't affect you as a YouTuber. That
didn't that's not how Nick felt when it was Dan going after Twitch
and Dan Clancy and advertisers. Nick Dioro felt like no no no
like doing that has bad implications for me as a streamer, as
a YouTuber on this platform. So, no, I'm not going to support
that. So, the fact that he would literally when it's it's Dan
going after specifically Twitch say, "No, that has implications
for me as a YouTuber and I'm I'm not going to just like act like
there's a difference." But now he's going to sit here and act
like there's a difference. It just feels really dishonest. Yeah.
And I think Well, hold on. It's a little dishonest, but he does
do the but right. So, this is right that you can ignore it. But
I'm telling you, he's in terms of like what he's going to say
if you were arguing back to you go, "Well, no, I I acknowledge
that there are downsides for all of us, potentially scary consequences,
right? I I I admit that this is disingenuous." I'm telling you
that's what he would argue, right? And then when Dan was making
his argument, Dan said, "But I don't care because anti-semitism.
I am I have to think about my children's future." And Nick was
like, "Yeah, no. This is my career." Yeah, true. That didn't
work on him then, but now it's Ethan's kids. Okay, now Ethan
at CPS called on him. Now, now all morals are out the window.
Okay, that principal that that wasn't a principal. Okay, now
it's Ethan's kids. He didn't care about Dan's kids. Cares about
Ethan's kids. Okay. Did you know that there were skulls sent
for every one of Ethan's kids? Cherry, did you know that? I didn't.
I didn't. Was it his kids' sk schools? No. And I don't think
it's true, actually. I think that was just something somebody
said. But I just don't know why it's What's actually crazy is
that you believe that for a second. You believe that could be
true. Isn't that the crazy part? I just don't know why his empathy
is important to need to disclose to anyone like uh you're a sociopathic
fat streamer on YouTube. Why do we care what you feel empathetic
towards if anything? I would never call Nick fat. Okay, that's
up. Kelly, why would you do that? Why? He's gigantic. You know,
I'm just glad that he felt empathy for Pixie. I can at least
point to one woman he had empathy for. Very cool. This is actually
a common destiny take strategy where you make an emotional argument
that sounds like you're making an argument on principle where
so like you might say, "I don't care if you get shot at Trump
rally." Uh that's not actually saying anything. You're just saying
how you feel about it, but it sounds like you're saying it's
justified or something like that. something edgy that you can
like defend on logical grounds. It's actually just a statement
of your emotion. It's the same thing Nick's doing here. He's
going to constantly make the emotional argument because it means
because he well he's lost the intellectual one. That's the reality.
He knows he always will lose cuz you're [__] I mean
that's evident when you turn to us verse them factor like galvanizing
people to support you in a dishonest way by implying that the
other side is actually against you. kind of like Ethan saying,
"I'm saving the commentary community by going after these people
because they're actually jeopardizing you even though he's the
one who's putting them in jeopardy." Well, I Yeah. I I And I
can't stand that. I I can't stand when somebody is like uh
like I want people to lie to me better sometimes. You know what
I'm saying? Like if you're going to lie to me, could you not
make it like the most obvious lie that I can like see the window
dressing on it? Like I could see I could see that this is an
illusion. Just lie better. Lie better. I don't really have to
lie to you thankfully because you're funny and all of your jokes
land and make me laugh. Huh? That's what I That's what I'm talking
about. Okay. Just lie better. See, you said that with feeling.
You said that with gusto. I believed it completely. Also because
it's true. Mostly because it's true, actually. Yeah. Mostly because
it's true.
I'm still waiting for Second to respond to me. second said, "Oh,
if you wanted an example of one of those times where you can't
criticize Denims and Co side without also full throatly criticizing
the Ethan side, uh, I don't see where that happened here and
I asked you what the criticism of denims was, and you still haven't
told me, and I'm specifically not scrolling up because I want
you to tell me from memory, but it seems like you're not telling
me from memory, so I'm very confused." What was the criticism?
I don't know what the criticism was. It's still not coming. It's
still not coming through. I don't know if you're telling me or
not. That the Twitch community's response. No, no, no. He's not
even saying the Twitch community's response. He says some streamers
were arrogant about it, but it wasn't it wasn't the Twitch community's
response. That wasn't most streamers. There were a couple streamers
who were arrogant about it. This is about Twitch's response,
right? Twitch as a platform didn't respond. This isn't a criticism
of denims. I just want to point out that it's clearly not what
you just said it was. But anyway, we can keep reading. Like thing
is that the things Twitch should do the Twitch's response being
poor is like their copyright and DMCA system isn't as developed
as YouTube. So they should probably, you know, have better tools.
Okay. So what does that have to do with Ethan Klein registering
his copyright with Library of Congress in advance of his video
to get statuto damages on these people? What the does DMCA process
or any like that have to do with the Library of Congress filing?
It's got it's like totally irrelevant. No better process would
have fixed this because
complete bad behave like no but he actually explicitly like this
the DMCA thing through Twitch does work. He literally could have
DMC it intentionally did not right and it took four hours created
before it was it was Anna. She DMCAD me. Yeah. But then she took
it back. Awesome.
But that's Thank you. I don't know. I like so obviously when
he's when he knows he's going to try to sue when he knows he's
going to register it. He easily could have DMCA. He just explicitly
didn't. So yeah, this isn't even a good It doesn't matter that
the system's not good. He didn't even attempt DMCA. Unless he
just hasn't told anybody about it, but I don't know why you wouldn't
put that in the lawsuit. Seems kind of like an important thing
to include in a lawsuit, right? Whether or not you DMCA this
guy seems sort of important. Hold on. I also, if you guys could
talk for two seconds, I'm going to switch some onream overlay
stuff.
I'll read the rest of the So, we agreed there's no reason for
him to think about Twitch as a platform right now. This is just
um you imagine him and like where's Sumo Wrestling?
No. No, I don't want to imagine that. Okay, hold on. Okay, Kelly's
working now. Queen is Queen
Okay. Yes, everybody's working. Everybody's working. We're good.
We're good to go. All right. So, when I think about Twitch as
a platform, I often look back I oftentimes look back to a truly
absurd email I received in back in 2021. In 2007, YouTube launched
its content ID system in uh system in and it allegedly cost $100
million to develop by 2018.
On May 28th, 2021, Twitch fired off a panic email begging their
users to learn about copyright and saying they were caught off
guard by automated content claims. YouTube created Content ID
after a lawsuit to tackle a growing copyright problem on its
site over a decade before Twitch sent me this this email promising
an ability to view your strike count in Twitch Studio. This is
absolutely
Um, okay. So, what so what would these change have done to prevent
this?
What?
This lawsuit isn't suing Twitch. It's not going to cause these
changes.
So, uh, the point total nons. Do you consider this is just to
bring up Twitch bad, but yeah, obviously it's just like, wow,
isn't this so terrible? Anyway, I'm going to get on stream tonight
and uh betray all my previous stage values and say this awesome.
Actually, that's all it is. Uh, do you think he did that on his
stream? I didn't get a chance to watch his stream at all. I haven't
been sent any clips yet, so I haven't watched any of it's like
I I can I'm sure at some point he goes, "Um, yeah, I don't know,
man. This this could be dangerous, I guess." But I'm sure the
rest of it is, "Oh my god, I'm so glad Casey drs be financially
ruined. Oh my god, dude. Then they don't even give a They've
got malicious intent. Like, how can this not be infringement?
It's going to be that like endlessly five." I actually
talked about that last night. You honestly can't check it out.
He's like doing the
I don't know if it's a strategy cuz it's maybe being too um thinking
too highly of him, but he's doing longass streams and he's doing
like lore dives. So, it's just I think the the stream talking
about Ethan was like a 12-hour stream because he wanted to look
up older content. Streamers can literally say whatever they want
because they put out so much content and no one's ever going
to sift through it. So, Exactly. And they're going to be like,
"Oh, they just clipped this moment out of a 12hour stream." Like,
okay, buddy, but can I not say anything unless I go over all
12 hours? At which point, what do you then then you just like,
I don't know, strike me. Okay. Me, cuz isn't that what Ethan
is doing? They went over the whole video. Now, I got to get them.
I'm going to go now. Good night, Kelly. Good night. Good night,
Kelly. See you. I was kind of hoping when I went and looked at
Nick's uh this post from Nick, I was going to see some responses.
So, he he goes on to say, "I genuinely think Twitch and what
it's allowed is pretty bad for the entire content creator landscape.
I've been saying there would be a huge lawsuit eventually that
could threaten all content creators for little years. And the
response from streamers has been, "You want me to react harder?
Why not make better content?" Is this going to change? Is this
going to change like the Twitch landscape right now?
I mean, it's So, it could open up to lawsuits, but it like it's
not fixing the problem. This isn't going to make this isn't suing
Twitch for not having a good Why do you think YouTube is any
different? Why do you think YouTube is any different? It's not
well you you couldn't make a a differentiation right at maybe
at this old just the content ID system but the content ID system
has nothing to do with this whatsoever. It's totally irrelevant.
I think this is just an old argument cuz YouTube used to not
be able to compete with live streaming, but that's changed over
the years. So if you're just falling back to uh Twitch versus
YouTube arguments uh from like four years ago, you're outdated.
YouTubers absolutely compete right now when it comes to live
streaming. Wouldn't you say? Yes, it absolutely competes. But
like I would say to me more the the issue is like none of these
people have ever really wanted to kind of complain about live
streaming. I think most of these people conceded in the 2023
debate that they they thought live streaming was like kind of
a gray area. Uh that audience is going to be more interested
in the streamer. The issue is always the VODs and where the VODs
were going and where the VODs like if you're competing on YouTube
with people who have like curated content on YouTube. And none
of this lawsuit has anything to do with that. All the people
who do that can still just do it right. It's basically only if
this lawsuit goes the worst way it could for creators unless
it all creators by like changing totally what fair use is going
to mean then no XQC who's the primary I guess primary offender
here is still taking all of the YouTube revenue he wants from
all of these people like literally the the stated target the
stated like worst behavior worst um worst offender for this problem
from 2023 is literally not going to be affected by this unless
it all creators I don't understand what the goal is so I understand
the differentiation with like VODs. I think XQC brought that
up and then like Ethan
acknowledged, okay, there there could be a thing there if the
Twitch VODs pull away viewership, but that's not as utilized
on like the Twitch platform as it is on YouTube. I think he said
I think he said that VODs basically don't compete. Like he he
created like a gray area for Twitch and said like I don't really
think that counts because like they're not competing in the same
Like nobody like Leo's not point. Go ahead. Oh, Lemino is not
um Lemino is not like streaming his videos on Twitch like it
is a separated audience was like the argument Ethan was making
back then. Yes. And I do believe that with the feature of YouTube
premieres and understanding that um the viewership that you get
during your premiere will boost you in the algorithm and can
affect your video going viral and like to the degree it'll go
viral. I thought that was the huge thing that he's actually like
zoning in on right here. are live streamers. They are live streaming
my live premiere and that's like a market replacement because
it is a live viewing experience with a live chat. I thought that's
what was going on.
I don't think I unless I'm mistaken, I'm not sure that Ethan
makes that actual argument. I like I don't I don't recall that
from the document, but I think that is that is the argument he
should be making, I think. Okay. But in that case, I I literally
don't know if fair use changes at all for streams versus uh like
stream versus stream versus like a curated video. Yeah, I'm just
I'm really not sure. But I don't I actually don't know that in
the market replacement thing, but yeah, I don't know. Uh like
it is the best argument. I know Cherry made that argument like
that that is why it's the most offensive when we first covered
this, but I don't know if that's I don't know if that's the argument
Ethan made.
Yes, because you can track the the actual market that's being
replaced by looking at what Denim's regular live viewership is
and then where it spiked to when she started watching the live
premiere, how much it spiked, how they retained, and when she
stopped watching it that they go away and that the next day that
she streams, they do not come back. you did effectively.
I I don't know if she can take it from Ethan, but you can argue
she had an audience to do this and it's because she did this
um stealing this like live premiere, not because these are people
invested in her. Sure. And then yeah, the counter-argument to
that is the Hassan and and H3 Stark people literally boosting
her in those communities to try to pump viewership to her and
and for that could be her argument. Hassan wasn't streaming.
Hassan uh advertised me and so Hassan viewers were watching me
and that could be a perfect like justification on her part. I
think that's fair to say. Yeah, I think it's gonna be interesting
to see which way it goes because I do think I I've kind of gotten
more convinced that I think there's a decent argument that she
did not actually create a market replacement.
I think I've like okay intellect in terms of intellectual honesty
I actually believe she did not create a market replacement because
she doesn't go and like upload it to YouTube uh herself and like
create uh like I I just don't think she did anywhere near what
like somebody like XTC does in terms of competing in that same
marketplace. I think she is explicitly being watched not because
it's the content nuke but because it is opposition to the content
nuke. I think that people Yeah. literally want opposition to
it. And it's like watching, you know, I wouldn't watch a Trump
rally. This is the comparison I used. Wait, were you here earlier?
You might have been here, Jerry, actually. But I I wouldn't watch
a Trump rally personally just to watch a Trump rally, but I might
watch it through a political content creator hypothetically,
right? Who's going to oppose it to explain like why it's like
I I hate this guy. I'm not going to watch him just talk. I think
that's how most people think, right? It's why political streamers
are so big
as well. This one as well. Um, Aerodite was live tonight. 170
viewers. If I stream sniped her, it'd be what? 500. Uh, maybe
higher. Higher. Be honest. I'm
Oh, yeah. Yeah. For a night content. And if you had I mean, I
assume if you were going to stream sniper, there would be like
a large impetus. There'd be some reason you were doing it. And
you get people who like aren't even regular viewer. Like, there
are people who will watch you. Probably there's like a decent
cohort of people who will watch Queen just for like airite hate
content. Soating that perhaps she could come after anyone for
reacting when it's like literally no one wants to watch your
stream. It's just you.
Yes. It is like
it's like Christian going after people for like making videos
on on them. It's her. It's like uh no one's no one's there to
watch you, bro. Okay. They need it filtered down.
Yeah. And I think there there is something when it's like critical
when it's criticism. It is like a fundamentally different product
you are creating like totally at a base level. There's nobody
who's like I'm a big fan of this person. I like their arguments.
I want to watch them cuz I think all of us do this. I remember
I used to do this for political streamers all the time. I turn
on like a rally or something and I hear them say something stupid
and I go, "Oh, I got to get out of here. I got to go just watch
the rally like this."
Right? Like I think when it's criticism of the content, it's
like it becomes fundamentally different from the underlying content.
I think that is a fairly solid argument for denims. Who's watching
Hassan if someone's not criticizing them and like you know Dior
or Willie Mac or Destiny or whoever's audience? I need to sit
on this for a bit because there's like an analogy right at the
tip of my tongue and I just can't find it. But I get what you
mean. You should have to actually do something to prove market
replacement because you can identify here there is a flux of
people that is coming to watch this streamer review this content.
Why do they never go to that content to actually see it themselves
or
well the H3 snark subreddit is actually the proof of this in
and of itself. There's a large community that Ethan argues is
huge right and is the primary community supporting like denims
and the creators against him. That's a huge community who regardless
of if Denims was doing that would have been watching it through
like the YW YouTube thing would have been watching it in a way
that wasn't going to pass revenue onto Ethan, right? Like they
that's why you bring up uh what is it 4chan or a Kiwi Farms?
Because for someone like Chris Chan to look at all of these people
talking about him and being like, "Oh, somebody must be taking
viewership away from me because look at all this like uh discussion
of me.
Other people are getting views of me, but my live streams aren't
getting any."
that person's like completely missing the reason why people are
watching.
Yeah, it's just like a hater content which I mean you could argue
that the haters should have to pay you in some way to use that.
You could make that argument but it's like it's not a market
replacement argument. No, think about think about can you or
should this be oh this person you'd have to prove that they are
actually doing something malicious by criticizing you. You'd
have to argue I need this content taken down for bullying and
harassment or something. Maybe maybe I'm just describing like
uh like as long as it's fair use, right? As long as it's transformative
enough, as long as it's not uh I think the market replacement
thing is the hardest one to argue. Feel like that's fine. Yeah.
Well, and especially when it becomes political, which all of
this stuff was, right? I think politics in terms of the nature
of the work itself absolutely opens up basically a ton of political
content to fair use. Like I think that becomes a very important
pillar when it is political content. You shouldn't be able to
make significant political crit criticisms of somebody and then
stop them from responding.
Um and stop them from responding maybe even in full to like something
like that, right? You're you're criticizing their movement, multiple
people in the same movement. I don't know that you can necessarily
say, "Well, I don't want them to I only want them to react to
my criticism with them." It's like, no, if you're criticizing
like these people and identifying them as a group, I think that's
I think that group might gain, you know, some ability to respond
to that. Now, I think like you're right, but I do believe that
that is what makes people feel like it's uh even more justified
to do so. I don't think that you have to
have initiated by criticizing a group to to open yourself up
for other people criticizing you. No, you don't. You don't. But
I'm saying that like it's an additional thing that you're like
advertising this as major criticisms of uh you're advertising
this this as major criticisms of this entire group, this like
ideological group that streams together. I think that group might
gain through those criticisms some right to respond to that work
and possibly the entire context
because this is obviously going to be different from video content
creation and like people earning revenue through views. But what
about critics who post bad reviews and then all of a sudden a
restaurant is like, I got this bad review from a critic and now
people don't come to my restaurant. They haven't even tried my
food. They just listen to what this person says and he actually
ruined every he ruined my career because of what maybe it was
like a bad day for him. I think that is some something close
to the criticism that they're making right in the lawsuit is
basically because this is like lying damage actually because
it's lying. It's like malicious and it's like actually hurting
my business for no discernable reason. No like no reasonable
cuz you would think that the person in the who owns the restaurant
runs the restaurant he is so devastated. I'm assuming it's a
man um is emotional. He's so devastated because these people
are going to read a review about his food without ever trying
it for themselves. But here is this person who is reacting to
your entire content. They can see the viewers can watch your
entire content through them. And you believe that that's hurting
your reputation, ruining your career? Yeah. I don't Well, I mean,
he's technically not suing for defamation, so I guess it's not
necessarily That's not his primary complaint, right? It is just
that it's infringing on his copyright. Yeah, but no, he doesn't
actually care about his copyright. He cares about how malicious
people were for doing what they If he could sue them for defamation,
he would sue them for defamation. Like he would rather sue them
for defamation to have that on the record that they're lying
about him, right? But he's suing them for copyright infringement
because he can't get them for defamation.
He's probably been told as much multiple times now. Uh this probably
doesn't have a good overlap, but that's like the closest thing
I can think of. Yeah, I think um because you can argue that a
food critic can actually ruin somebody's restaurant and reputation
without anybody
uh without even being accurate, right? Because it is just like
your opinion,
why does it have so much weight to it? I don't think that YouTubers
or streamers have that much power, but maybe I'm being naive.
I don't know. Yeah, it uh I mean it depends. I think it's more
about the group. They think they they're basically taking this
is like uh actually something a lot of people do online. They'll
take the actions of the whole group and they'll hold a single
person responsible, right? Regardless of how much sense that
makes like Dennis is getting blamed for like coordinating with
Snark and causing like all of those viewers to like by announcing
that she was going to do a replacement, causing all of those
viewers to go to her channel. Like it's she's basically going
to be held responsible for the actions of like tens of thousands
of people. Seems a little crazy to me.
And for and for what? because his video got millions of views,
right? And his videos continue to get millions of views. It shouldn't
he actually, I don't know, be hurting in some way for him to
be able to make an effective change? I usually, but that's the
entire purpose of registering with the Library of Congress so
that he can like do sue statutoily so that like usually it would
just be actual damages like what are you what are you would you
how are you harmed? Show me that you're harmed and I will you
could just get restitution through the courts. But he knows that
he's not going to actually be harmed by these people. He knows
there's no real actual harm there. And so he is just suing for
statutory damages to try to hurt these people as much as possible.
He's a mean, vindictive bully. Principalist loser. Yeah. Okay.